if you're living your life right you've
already finished every episode of jordan
bloom and pat and oswald's hulu series
marvel's modoc
across 10 episodes the show brings
viewers into the life of the man
described as comics most iconic
mechanized organism designed only for
killing and draws the curtain back on
his problematic approach to finding a
work-life balance
this take on modoc is a reimagining far
removed from his usual appearances in
marvel comics
sure there's cackling and a healthy dose
of super science machinations but his
villainous behavior is presented less as
an alien philosophy
and more like the pursuits of a guy in
his 40s who's still trying to make it as
a stand-up comedian
modok might have noble intentions but
they're rooted in the same delusion that
turns otherwise capable adults into
story-eyed monuments to arrested
development
for the millionth time it won't work
you can't have it all yes i
can i'm very special
his moral gradient is black and white
there are good people like modoc's mom
who told him that he was special
everyone else falls into the same
category as the bullies who beat him up
their behavior will need to be corrected
hey we're people not to me it's a
flailing simplistic world view
illustrated by modoc's dramatic
all-or-nothing way of dealing with
well literally everything throughout the
show's 10 episodes mordock takes the
baby steps appropriate for a man of his
head-to-leg ratio
thanks in large part to his forced
reckoning with family life here's how
marvel's modoc wraps up
and what it all means as the series
progresses little by little modock makes
a gradual transition towards being a
better father
he's still not great in the end but you
know what he's okay
he dances with his son lou at his bar
mitzvah acknowledges his shortcomings to
his wife jody and even elicits a
positive emotion from his daughter
melissa which is difficult when you're
parenting any teenage girl let alone one
with the dominant super villain gene
but morocco is still haunted by the man
he was 20 years ago and in this case
it's literal
the time displaced morocc from the past
finds his present self and reminds him
of what he wanted to be
past mordock shows his older self all of
the futures that could occur
deaths at the hands of every avenger
toilet heart attacks and presciently
that one potential outcome that sees
modoc become the ruler of a utopian
unified earth
you're a super villain you hate the
world
no i don't i just want to change it it's
a strange setup that calls back to dr
strange's infinity war scenario of a one
chance in 14 million for victory with
one dark
difference in infinity war tony stark
has come to terms with how much of
himself he'll sacrifice while modoc can
succeed only if he sacrifices others
specifically the family that he worked
so hard to deserve
the key word there the one that cemented
the family's doom
is worked it's unavoidable that marvel's
modoc is going to be compared to adult
swims rick and morty as they both have
science fiction elements pop culture
references and self-serving cartoon
geniuses so it's fitting that a line
from rick and morty can sum up the
general theme of modoc season one
the thing about repairing maintaining
and cleaning is
it's not an adventure there's no way to
do it so wrong you might die
it's just work that's a conundrum at the
center of modoc take the exciting
destructive dramatic path or keep
working at the day-to-day aspects of
life
nco kill iron man or clean your
apartment conundrum
one option means that modok's mother was
right and he's a very special boy
the other means doing the work and if
his younger self is to be believed
never becoming what he dreamed he would
be melissa's earlier attempts to teach
her old man how to take the subtle
effective route to echo through his
decision
and modoc stands at the same proverbial
fork in the road as every dad that's
ever thought about just getting in the
car and driving away from it all with a
slight addendum of a dozen rockets being
fired at his kids
then comes the flash forward modok chose
the first option
like dr horrible before him modoc has
everything he's ever wanted at the cost
of the lives of the people he loved
yes he's keeping his younger self
tethered to a torture device using his
chrono crystal facial bedazzling to look
back
on what he lost but wanting his family
back doesn't mean that he fixed the part
of him that threw them away to begin
with
untold years and a few dozen avenger
deaths later and grand dramatic gestures
are still modok's only approach to
problem solving
like the darkest possible iteration of
murphy brown modock declares that he
will have it all
how that'll pan out remains to be seen
series co-creator jordan bloom has
hinted that a second season is already
planned out so fans should get excited
for more modoc misadventures in the
hopefully near future
yeah let's just get out of here check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite superhero television shows are
coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]